we'd love to hear about your next  product it's actually a an adaptation of  a very popular video game series how  dare you try to spit in God's face what  is a well-known rule that a video game  cannot be successfully adapted into  another medium I know that's something  that you know people like to to say but  uh it really isn't true I mean there's  there's so many good TV and movie  adaptations and videos no it has never  happened ever  shut up look I personally think give me  some examples well stop exactly okay wow  you're like Herzog making fitzgeraldo  how this was a good movie I like that  this is simply a law of nature are you  okay you will bring chaos upon your  people okay well no it has never  happened you're not aware of the video  game adaptation yeah I I get your point  yeah dumb  dummy dumb dumb dumb all right